salut tout le monde l'essentiel sur les
prospects de la draft NBA 2023
vous fait les portraits en 20 minutes de
des membres du Top 20 attendus allez
plus quelques autres noms plus
évidemment les Français de cette de
cette draft voici l'essentiel sur aux
arts Thompson
Ozar Thompson né le 30 janvier 2003
frère jumeau d'Amen Thompson il y en a
un qui joue plus avec le ballon c'est
amen il y en a un qui joue plus 100
ballons c'est aux arts en tout cas cette
année donc il a déjà 20 ans 2 m 01 2 m
10 envergure comme son frère un peu plus
lourd 99 kg il a aussi des plus grandes
mains c'est ce que nous a révélé le NBA
draft combine 7e du Big board envergure
numéro 2 qui est sorti il y a quelques
jours on enregistre fin mai cinquième
chez ispn et the Ringer 7e chez the
athletic aux Arch Thompson pour en
parler nous sommes avec Thomas et
Yassine comme pour son frère on est là
Thomas c'est toi qui
commenceon comment comment a-t-il grandi
ou est-il né
alors pour les gens qu'on qui viennent
d'écouter ou qui écouteront Thompson on
va donc se répéter donc aux arc Thompson
et nez comme son frère le 30 janvier
2003 tu es de la dialecte donc dans la
banlieue de San Francisco proche de
clanes donc il est dans une famille de
sportive son grand frère treuil Thompson
a joué en division en NCA après review
c'est un c'est un bon shooter
contrairement aux deux jumeaux liés
entre 2016 et 2018 son oncle Mark
Thomson a le fait représenter la
Jamaïque aux JO de Barcelone en 92 donc
aux 400 mètres haies pour information il
avait fini 3e mais il était discret
disqualifié je suis allé voir la course
pour le divertissement
donc pour comme Hamming Thompson donc
son père les a vraiment formaté à
devenir des athlètes de haut niveau 17
ans ils ont été vraiment vraiment
traînés rapidement
dans ce processus également ils ont fait
l'école à la maison à partir de leur 11
12 ans donc sa mère Maya Wilson et donc
son
ont décidé de faire cela avec son
grand-père notamment Claude Wilson qui
leur donnait une éducation pour
s'améliorer spirituellement
culturellement pour améliorer leur
travail à l'école exactement en même
temps mieux comprendre certaines choses
donc ça leur a permis dans ce même temps
de beaucoup travailler à l'extérieur sur
le basket donc ils sont très rapidement
très rapidement et des éthiques de
travail très importantes pour progresser
dans quelque chose qui était déjà leur
but très tôt dans leur vie ensuite comme
amène les ont bougé du côté de la
Floride où ils ont fait leur High School
du côté de pinkest ils ont donc fait
leur année High School là-bas ils ont
été champion lors de leur année junior
les deux joueurs ont été mdrides comme
de l'État les deux joueurs ont toujours
été vraiment inséparables du côté du
basket il disait cette année dans une
interview donc l'année dernière ils
étaient pas dans la même équipe cette
année c'était dans la même équipe en
overtime mais l'année dernière donc
quand ils sont affrontés c'est la
première fois depuis
9 ans qui s'affrontaient contre dans un
match qui sera un mini camp disait-il
donc vraiment des joueurs qui ont
toujours été inséparables au niveau du
basket et pour rajouter quelque chose
par rapport à amen même si on parle un
peu plus de ce dernier du meneur de
l'overtime aux arc Thompson c'est lui
qui a été deux fois champion il était
champion cette année avec son frère il
était champion l'an dernier sans son
frère et il a été élu deux fois MVP de
Lover time donc c'est lui qui a des
trophée dans sa chambre à la maison
c'est le winner des deux exactement et
pourtant il est prévu un tout petit peu
plus bas puisque amène Thompson et plus
projeté
4/5 de la draft aux arc Thompson et bien
c'est on l'a dit entre entre 5 et 7e
donc il y a pas une grosse différence
mais voilà quel rôle cette année Yassine
pour aux arc Thompson du côté de
l'overtime Elite qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait qu'est-ce qu'on lui
demande d'être faire en fait et comment
il l'a fait
la premièrement il était dans la même
équipe que son frère il était plus il
jouait plus au football c'était le son
le second porteur de balle il se
partageait là-bas lui et son frère par
moment
il a tourné à du 16 principes à cette
rebond en 27 minutes
par contre lors des pilots il a
nettement augmenté le son scoring avec
21 points 5 rebonds 4 passes des
interceptions et un bloc
son volume de tir il a 12 tirs par match
il tourne à 48 %
proche du cercle il a 56% sur 9
tentatives il va souvent au cercle
à trois points il y a une progression
durant sa première année l'état 19%
cette saison il tourne à 30% sur quatre
tentatives par match il y a une
progression
il va 5 fois sur la ligne mais son
pourcentage au lancer franc n'est pas
n'est pas terrible que 66%
, il tourne à trois blocs par match un
sacré défenseur on en parlera après par
contre il a 5 balles 5 paires de balles
par match
ça c'est à souligner et donc c'est les
ballons il est touché comment est-ce que
c'était de la transition est-ce que
c'était de l'attaque placée où il
sortait d'écran enfin c'était quoi ces
touches de ballon puisqu'il tentait
beaucoup de tir par moment c'était des
attaques placées sur Demi terrain
comme je l'ai dit je partageait là-bas
lui et son frère donc par moment c'était
lui qui initiait le jeu il a un peu plus
de mal dans ce domaine là
se précipite beaucoup
des choix douteux voilà pourquoi il a 5
paires de balles après les capable de
joindre transition il est il a un coffre
il va vite il peut il peut accélérer le
jeu de son équipe ok quelle est sa carte
d'entrée en NBA pourquoi on draft
Thompson Thomas on gratte un hasard
Thomson car c'est un ailier très
athlétique comme son frère un peu moins
que son frère notamment au niveau du
premier pas mais ça a donc un eliatrique
vraiment très complet je trouve et c'est
faire beaucoup de choses sur un terrain
déjà c'est un bon scorer largement il
est meilleur score c'est faire plus de
choses il a beaucoup plus ce craft du
scoring c'est technique de scoring il a
des bons appuis non très bon dribble et
un meilleur triple son frère son frère
très le dribble vraiment bien mais là
encore trop d'imprécisions dans son
crime notamment il fallait encore un peu
trop vite par rapport à par rapport à
son vraie vie je suis pas tout le temps
aux arts et beaucoup plus sous contrôle
il a vraiment un très très fort humble
un des de la CUV il a des beaux appuis
il est capable de plus pour dans le jeu
intermédiaire il est également plutôt
bon pour aller à l'arceau il sait finir
dès demain également rappelle les mêmes
soucis que son frère je me rappelle les
mêmes soucis au global ces soucis de
régularité dans les finitions il est
plus jouable au vol comme on l'a dit
c'est notamment un bien meilleur shooter
con son frère il y a une vraie
progression cette année il a quasiment
30% sur l'année mais si on enlève la
précision il y a 34% sur la saison
Otis avec les play-offs sur 21 matchs et
il a fini la saison de la plus belle des
manières j'ai envie de dire vu qu'il a
mis 15-3 points sur les quatre derniers
matchs qu'il a vraiment pris feu il a
notamment mis le buzzers pour donner le
titre à son équipe sur un 3 points sur
une base de son frère donc il a vraiment
fini la saison en beauté pour pour
rappeler au scout qu'il avait beaucoup
plus d'obsides aux tire que son frère la
mécanique c'est améliorée dernièrement
même s'il a un corps il a un peu encore
ce corps courbé au niveau du bassin qui
est un peu vers l'arrière ça plus propre
que son frère sont beaucoup plus fluide
et on sent vraiment les progrès par
rapport à l'an passé donc à l'autre
continuer dans ce sens là donc c'est
vraiment comme je l'ai dit un Héli
complet en plus de de ce scoring et de
ce shoot qui est en avance par rapport à
son frère c'est un patient vraiment
capable c'est contrairement à même qui
est plus un primeur aux arômes à plus
des skills de bonhomme leur tertiaire
voir secondaire si ça améliore beaucoup
il est vraiment capable quand même de
mener de la taille si c'est jouer du pic
and roll il s'est trouvé de vrais belles
passes dans le Drive pour ses
coéquipiers dès demain également comme
son frère et en plus la défense comme
l'a dit Yacine il est plus appliqué
défensivement que son frère il est plus
sérieuse
j'allais dire justement sur sur la
défense Yassine vu que tu l'as évoqué en
premier je j'ai l'impression pour toi
c'est son atout numéro 1 il y a
le côté le côté chien de garde
exactement pour moi il a un footwork
très avancé ce qui lui permet de très
bien défendre sur n'importe quel joueur
en oeuvre tamily puisque c'est des
jeunes mais je le vois défendre sur
plusieurs postes en NBA comme je l'ai
dit en NBA on a toujours besoin de
défenseur qui est capable de garder les
stades vertes et je pense que lui il est
vraiment capable lui il est vraiment
capable en plus il peut vivre par en
attaque peut vivre sans ballon c'est une
menace proche du cercle peut finir en
aller houppe peut finir en bout de
chaîne
donc je pense que c'est ça peut être un
soldat en NBA un bon un bon soldat
tu voulais ajouter un truc sur la
défense
non très fort défenseur un peu à l'image
de son frère finalement dans le profil
genre très athlétique très rapide très
long donc très dur à passer en
rencontrant également en aide il fait
les rotations au cercle il joue les
lignes de passe donc un gros playmaker
défensif également donc quand il a
vraiment un profil complet pour défendre
de 1 à 3 déjà et sur des petits cas tous
ces potentiellement il a vraiment profil
défensif très complet dans tous les sens
du terme même si comme son frère est un
corps des petits sautes de concentration
par moments genre qui va pouvoir être
dans le dos c'est aussi des gens qui
grumbellent pas mal d'interception après
c'est également le jeu de l'over time
qu'il voulait beaucoup de jeux rap et
beaucoup de transition un peu trop de
chaud par moment donc avec plus de
serions NBA a vraiment du très très gros
potentiel en défense par le de lui comme
son frère personnellement comme des
potentiels
on va parler de ce qu'on pourrait
développer chez
oser Thompson pour toi qu'est-ce qui
devrait développer pour devenir vraiment
un joueur incontournable en NBA et
qu'est-ce qui pourrait débloquer son
potentiel et du coup
s'il développe ce skill quel potentiel
il a
moi je le vois vraiment un bon role
Player pour moi développer son tir à
trois points il en est progression et
pourquoi pas être un trading
à son équipe la défense ce genre de jour
là on en a toujours besoin et je pense
que si il arrive à
avoir un tire fiable à trois points être
un bon défenseur je le vois rester
longtemps à NBA
carrière effectivement
ne jamais trop de bons défenseurs qui
sont pas un poids pour le spacing mais
c'est vrai qu'on part de 30%
tu es optimiste sur la meilleure version
de son tir
après quand je vois que l'année passée
l'état 19 là à 30 je me dis que pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas si on a si le travail
je peux y croire mécaniquement t'as pas
noté de trucs de bizarrer quoi
il a un peu stabilisé le tout non non
mécaniquement c'est que du travail je
pense pas que ça soit sa mécanique le
problème OK
c'est peut-être ces mains très large il
y a des mains très larges
c'est jamais un gros atout
des grosses mains pour shooter
Thomas est-ce qu'il y a un style en
particulier tu te dis vraiment là il
faut qu'il développe ça et qui signe à
coup sûr une longue carrière
le style qui pourrait faire craquer son
plafond je pense c'est continuer
d'améliorer son son scoring au global
son jeu de scoring en tant porteur de
balle donc son jeu de poulet comme je
l'ai dit c'est un largement meilleur
score que ce sera beaucoup plus complet
et là il est capable de pull off déjà
cette année de la faire de nombreuses
reprises notamment à mi distance il a
vraiment il a vraiment un sens un sens
du scoring un sens du panier même aux
trois niveaux donc c'est vraiment très
intéressant ça c'est vraiment le
scénario plus plus il arrive vraiment de
bien développer son scoring humble donc
ça ce sera pour le meilleur des
scénarios mais dans un scénario un peu
plus classique je si il arrive à
continuer de progresser et de pour
devenir pardon un shooter correct à
trois points s'il arrive à atteindre les
35% sur un volume correct et qu'on qu'il
arrive à capitaliser sur cette fin de
saison pour continuer de progresser si
il ajoute ça à son package de scoring
notamment sur transition sur attaque de
cercle comme son frère il a un très bon
premier pas il est très athlétique
grosse détente grand in time donc il va
pouvoir très facile
se débarrasser de son défenseur sur des
clausats donc tu vas pouvoir jouer très
bien au football notamment sur du cut
c'est un très bon joueur sans ballon il
va pouvoir vraiment bien faciliter le
jeu de son équipe également moi j'aime
beaucoup son ping même si un corps un
peu trop de déchets notamment dans le
deuxième par moment plus ça défense il
est capable de très très haut niveau je
pense que ça peut être un élève vraiment
très complet des deux côtés du terrain
un jour qui est efficace on attaque un
jour qui est très bon défenseur un
joueur qui peut un peu améliorer le
passing complet d'une équipe donc je
pense qu'il a vraiment un potentiel très
élevé et juste il améliore son shoot et
qui comme son frère comme comme les
erreurs comme les
errements dans un peu tous les secteurs
de son jeu c'est pas vraiment de venir
un joueur très sérieux personnellement
j'aime beaucoup son profil
Yassine juste une question sur
l'attitude que tu as vu de Ozar pour toi
est-ce qu'il y a
un vrai un vrai truc positif ou négatif
à noter dans le côté attitude que ce
soit sur le terrain au bord d'une
interview tout ça
non j'ai pas forcément quelque chose à
noter après sur le terrain je le
trouverai je le trouve vraiment
un jour d'équipe qui qui peut apporter
NBA ça peut être un vraiment un rôle un
rôle clair il a une mentalité une très
bonne mentalité rien que je pense qu'en
over timide si tu vois quelqu'un
défendent c'est qu'il a une bonne
mentalité parce que là-bas ça on pense
qu'à l'attaque donc déjà ça pour moi
c'est un signe positif
la projection son rôle l'année prochaine
Thomas
ça va être un peu Triki à utiliser aux
arc Thompson quel rôle il peut avoir
qu'on a vu des rookies à voir ces
derniers temps
il peut avoir un rôle dans une rotation
en tant que en tant que défenseur après
tu vas dépendre de son choix si il
shoute plutôt correctement rapidement on
va pouvoir plus mettre sur le terrain si
ça redevient un peu trop compliqué et
que la fin de saison était juste un
petit coup de chaud il va être plus
durment utilisable mais je pense qu'il
peut quand même vraiment étudier dans
son jeu of ball dans sa capacité 4 c'est
son choix de transition si je suis pas
trop mal il va pouvoir rester sur le
terrain il va pouvoir défendre le
meilleur attaquant adverse si besoin et
qui est c'est l'arrivait être sérieux
rapidement il peut vraiment défendre
beaucoup de monde donc il a une de cette
versatilité défensive qui est
intéressante offensivement va pouvoir
faciliter le jeu de l'équipe également
il va avoir moins le ballon que son
frère forcément comme on l'a dit c'est
pas le même profil mais je pense qu'il
est potentiellement plus insérable dans
une équipe car il a moins besoin de la
balle donc on peut le mettre à côté
genre potentiellement plus bol dominante
plus fort donc je pense que dans pas mal
d'équipes et surtout donc les
équipements drafté au en loterie il va
pouvoir s'intérêt plutôt plutôt
potentiellement assez rapidement avoir
des bonnes minutes pour pour montrer ses
qualités et comme son frère c'est un
joueur qui a besoin de jouer a besoin de
prendre ce petit mur du haut niveau pour
continuer de progresser développer ses
skills continuer de Clean tout son jeu
pour pour devenir le genre qui peut
devenir donc je pense tu peux jouer
plutôt assez rapidement dans les équipes
qui vont rater assez haut
Yassine est-ce que tu crois aux arc
Thompson
et je crois plus en lui que son frère en
tout cas ok
Thomas on y croit ou pas
j'ai son frère 3 j'ai aux arcades donc
je crois beaucoup en les deux je pense
qu'il a un super profil et comme je l'ai
dit pas forcément besoin de venir un
génie du scoring pour avoir un super
rôle en NBA si s'il continue de bien
améliorer son 3 points il va avoir déjà
des points faciles grâce au son bol
grâce à ses transitions c'est le genre
de joueurs comme son frère qui peut
atteindre les 17 18 points par match je
pense en se développant bien et si la 18
points par match qui défend comme un
titan qui facilite le jeu de son équipe
qui prend des réponses est un genre
clairement évalué bol avec avec un pic
ou il a attendu donc s'il est le
développement se passe bien comme avec
son frère s'il travaille beaucoup s'il
est mis de bonnes dans bonne condition
et qui fait tout pour je pense qu'il a
vraiment un très beau futur devant lui
je pense que ça peut devenir un super
journalier donc ouais j'y crois beaucoup
même si comme son frère il faut rappeler
qui a forcément des risques
effectivement c'est pas les plus safe
mais de toute façon il y a jamais
beaucoup de save-pics dans une dans une
draft donc
osart Thompson voilà ce qui était notre
résumé pour lui le joueur de la overtime
Elite qui lui aussi sera à surveiller le
soir de la draft parce que
l'overtime élite joue gros dans la draft
des deux jumeaux Thompson effectivement
leur de cette draft du mois de juin
merci Thomas merci Yacine et à bientôt
pour plus de podcasts concernant les
prospects 2023 de la draft NBA